on termine ce journal avec une autre
idée de promenade pour ce week-end si
vous n'avez pas l'intention d'aller
porte de versailles le salon des
maquettes et bien pouvait aller à
versailles tout simplement avec les
grandes zones musical qui rouvre
dimanche au public dans le parc du
château l'occasion d'une pérégrination
sur les pattes du roi-soleil reportage
michel perrier et jacques gérard
il y a trois cents ans les meilleurs
hommes de science de louis xiv se sont
mis à l' ouvrage ayant réussi à paris
qui donne encore le vertige amener de
l'eau à versailles
aujourd'hui encore au printemps les
grandes eaux musicales célèbres la
passion du roi pour ses jardins et ses
fontaines les jours en fait le marché
dans son jardin car il était très fier
de son oeuvre
ce géant représente la fronde écrasé par
le 14 qui devient roi et qui gouverne
sans ministre qui a aboli les des gens
entreprises opposants on peut ainsi si
un échec dimanche le parc en musique à l
écoute de lully ou bien rameaux qui ont
animé la vie de la cour une promenade
enrichie cette année par la restauration
de trois mosquées conçus par le nôtre
c'est vraiment le moment l'émotion
disons presque la maximale pour nous
c'est cette renaissance de ce
jaillissement de l'eau dans un décor que
l'on a complètement recomposée ça c'est
sûr que c'est des techniques modernes
mais c'est vraiment des effets des
effets history année et esthétique de
lenôtre conçus par le nôtre que l'on
arrive à faire revivre et c'est vrai que
ça c'est ce qu'il ya de plus émouvant
pour nous dans cette restauration du
jardin
une promenade d'après dîner pour louis
xiv un moment féerique pour nous
d'un bassin l'autre d'un point de vue à
l'autre dans le parc du château de
versailles
l'eau et partons souveraine
à